Hello and welcome back to the Rawkode Academy.
I'm your host, David Flanagan.
We're continuing our complete guide to Spin by
taking a look at some new features in
Spin one point o. This is a huge
milestone for Spin. Reaching one point o gives
us all some assurances
that Spin is now ready to use in
production.
In today's video, we're gonna focus on what
I personally feel is the coolest feature. What
is that feature?
OCI registry support.
You can now package your Spin applications as
an OCI artifact
and push it to an OCI registry
like Docker Hub or GHCR.
And while this is cool as it is,
there's a few other things that we can
do with these artifacts too and you'll see
them by watching the rest of this video.
Let's take a look. So what do we
have here?
This is a very standard
unedited spin new project using the Rust SDK.
I haven't modified anything.
This is just printing out hello fermion
with an HTTP header of the bar.
Again, I haven't touched anything. All I ran
was spin new.
From here, we can run spin build and
because I've already compiled it, it's super fast.
We can now run spin up and now
if we pop over to the browser, we
will see
our application is running on port 3,000 and
says hello Fermion.
We can even see the logs in our
console. So what is the next stage? Let's
build and push an OCI
artifact.
How do we do that? Well, I'm going
to run just push.
Inside of this directory, I have added a
just file and don't worry, we'll take a
look at it in just a moment. When
we run just push, you'll see that this
is a spin registry push command,
which takes a tag of GHCRDotIOSlashRawkodeSlashSpinDashOLColonV
1. I have now built an OCI
artifact, an OCI image, and pushed it to
GitHub's container registry. Don't believe me? Well, let's
pop over to GitHub
and refresh. And you'll see that I pushed
this image seven minutes ago.
Awesome.
So let's make a change and repush our
image. We'll go over to the code.
We'll say hello world,
like so. So now that we've modified that,
let's pop over here and this time we'll
just run the registry command ourselves.
We'll do registry push GHCR
raw code spin hello.
Only this time we'll call it v two.
What we should see is that we got
a different hash and two
content addressable
releases available on GSCR's
web page. Pop back over to the browser
and hit refresh. And now we can see
we have v two pushed a moment ago.
Okay.
But what can we do with our OCI
image once it's in an OCI registry? Well,
let's run just spin up. Now as you'll
see, when I hit return, the command is
a slightly modified spin up. And in fact,
I don't even need to be in this
directory to run this image. We're using spin
up dash f, which is telling it to
go to ghcr.i0/rawkode/spinhellovone.
This pulls down the artifact
and runs it locally. And again, if I
go to my browser, we get hello fermion.
But let's change this and run spin up
dash f j c r Rawkode
spin hello
v two. And again, it'll run on port
3,000
and when we reload,
we get hello world. So we now have
the ability to consume our spin applications
stored as OCI images instead of an OCI
registry.
And that is pretty cool. So let's take
it one step further and see something cool
that Docker also announced recently.
This is a spin application
using BarfollowMU.
BarfollowMU is a CMS
for WebAssembly.
We can take a look at the spin.toml
and see that this is just your standard
spin.toml.
It points to a WebAssembly module, in this
case, modules Bartholomew.
Also have a Dockerfile from scratch,
copy everything and the entry point is the
WebAssembly module itself.
Let's do docker image build dash t example
like so. Now, I've already built it to
speed it up, but it does normally take
a few seconds. Now that we have a
standard docker container image built now,
we can do docker container run, run time
equals
container d spin v one
mapping
the port,
like so.
And we want to run
the example
image that we have just built, like so.
Then we can come back over to our
browser and hit refresh. And now we see
the Barfolme new example
from the Docker documentation
of building and running Spin applications.
It has never been easier.
Now I just want to show one more
thing from the Docker support because it doesn't
stop at Docker image build and Docker container
run. You can actually add a Docker compose
dot YAML with any dependent services that you
have. Here we have a database of Postgres,
and we're also pulling down our example
image and given it the runtime information as
part of the spec.
Meaning, we can now do Docker Compose up
like so, And we'll see the database logs
as it begins to initialize.
But if we pop over here
and refresh our website,
and then go back to the terminal, you'll
see the request come in just like any
other Docker Compose app.
Sweet. Okay.
Let's finish this off with something even cooler.
Because our spin applications can now be shared
as OCI artifacts, we can hook in to
other tools that work with OCI artifacts.
And here, I'm talking about cosign.
What if we can actually sign
our spin applications that we ship as OCI
Artifacts?
So let's try it.
Let's do cosign
sign GHCRRawkode
Spin hello
b one.
This will pop open a browser allowing me
to connect with GitHub and sign our image
with those credentials.
So we can click yes on that and
the signature
will be pushed. So let's verify
the signature. So let's run cosign verify
g h c r dot I o slash
Rawkode slash Spin Hello
v two.
And we just need to add a few
flags because we use keyless signing, which means
we have to say that the certificate
identity
was me.
Like so.
And that the certificate
OIDC
issuer
with h t p s github dot com
slash login
slash o auth.
And make sure you spell all the all
the things correct.
Certificate.
No. We didn't sign v two, so we
get an error that no matching signatures were
there,
which is what we expect.
But I like to show it not working
before we show the shiny. So now v
one. And the signature is actually correct, but
I signed up with David at Rawkode dot
academy and not David@Rawkode.dev.
Quick fix later.
Clear the screen. So looks like magic. And
now we have everything from the transparency log
that assures us that this spin application
has been signed for by me
and it's the same one that is available
on the OCI registry.
Awesome.
So that's it. Since Spin one point o,
you can now build, ship, and run your
Spin applications as OCI artifacts. This allows you
to hook in to all of the existing
tooling in that space,
like Docker desktop, Docker compose, and even cosign.
In a video coming up later this week,
we'll be taking a look at taking these
OCI artifacts and running our spin applications on
Kubernetes.
We'll see you then. Have a great day.